hallo verehrtes publikum von heute im
wunderschönen dänemark genau genommen in
owen will und bei uns sind julian
franziskus und die beiden hier sind aus
deutschland aber wohnen dänemark
beziehungsweise haben hier gewohnt und
wir wollen heute unbedingt herausfinden
was typisch dänisch ist um was die
unterschiede zwischen dänemark und
deutschland sind
[Musik]
julia und fahren sie was macht ihr in
dänemark wie so lebt ihr hier
ich arbeite ja an hab auch hier studiert
also ich habe hier studiert war vor
einem jahr zwei jahre lang und jetzt
lebe ich aber wieder in deutschland wie
kommt man als deutscher darauf nach
dänemark zu ziehen
ich wollte ans meer und studieren
verhältnisse sind eigentlich auch besser
hier finde ich wollte auf englisch
studieren und hier gibt es keine
studiengebühren dass trainer wie
kleinere klassen
was mich jetzt interessieren würde weil
also in deutschland weiß man ja generell
sehr wenig über dänemark muss ich sagen
also fast gar nicht sondern ich mich
damit beschäftigt hat und dann so die
großen unterschiede zwischen deutschland
und dänemark
außer dass deutschland größer ist die
pop und mehr leute hat ein wort das man
nicht übersetzen kann dass du ein
bisschen wie kunst mit gemütlichkeit
viel eigentlich gelaufen lampen kommen
zusammenhang machen irgendwo streichen
oder also ich musik machen gerade im
winter wenn es dunkel ist kerzen
anzünden und sich einfach gemütlich
machen also die lage sein eine person
kann auch allgemein ganz kompliziert
stört ist dass die band das glücklichste
volk gewählt und nicht mehr
seit letzter woche in norwegen war sein
letzter film zu spät gekommen aber wieso
sind die sind so glücklich
also es gibt live band wird hier
ziemlich hoch angesehen als ist für mich
wichtig dass du neben arbeit halt auch
noch dein leben hast einfach und
also jemand würde er noch mal abends
arbeiten aber früher nach hause gehen
und hat den tag noch zu genießen
stimmt es dass die dänen noch
ordnungsliebender und spießiger sind als
die deutschen stolz auf irgendwann
später hatte ich hier in unsere das
gefühl dass die leute immer an der roten
ampel stehen beim auch nachts ja das
glaube ich so ein bisschen weil hier die
strafen einfach mehr anfragen gibt es
auch irgendwie eine bevormundung der
bevölkerung machen wir weiter was ist
das beste dänische essen für mich oder
für die dänen
ich bin vegetarierin und da hat man
keine chance so schwierig richtig rad
event schweiger ganzen welt man irgendwo
hinkommen zu einem meeting oder er das
ist nichts für vegetarier gefahren
was ist der schönste ort in dänemark
reservierter die deutschen und die denn
vielleicht man den zum ersten mal trifft
aber offen also ich finde beim ersten
mal treffen sind wir schon sind deutsche
offen
wenn sie so langsam auftauen dann hat
man ein schmerzmittel nehmen wer ist
denn direkter und ehrlicher sagt man ja
über beide völker stimmig was scheiße
aus ihr leid da haben die auch keine
tabuthema irgendwie so einfach
wer hat mehr humor
in irgendeiner situation beschreiben wie
ihr in dänemark erlebt ob dies in
deutschland nie geben würde
also mein mitbewohner fand das immer
komisch wenn also wir waren drei
deutsche in unserer wg und ein däne
und er fand es immer komisch wenn wir
uns am tisch die nato plant auch die
deutschen in der uni dänen haben sich
immer beschwert
das habe ich schon das habe schon vor
mehreren von euch gehört dass das
unmöglich ist in deutschland auch aus
und arabische länder habe ich das auch
weg welche sprache schwerer deutscher
wellness dänische aussprache deutsche
grammatik
wie kann man die deutsche aus frauen
beschreiben war das ist also die
verschluckt
und dann spricht sie anders auch daß sie
da stehen so dass man am besten spricht
man dänisch wenn man betrunken ist und
die kartoffeln und hat auf deutschland
würden wir sagen gänse und auf welche
sagen
stimmt ist dass die dänen ungern reisen
ich will sagen nein nein das habe ich
nur gehört darauf an wo man in dänemark
er kommt die leute aus vielen die reisen
nicht so gerne auch nicht so gerne nach
kopenhagen stimmt es dass wie den iris
lange über alles lieben und überall
aufhängen
so auch beim geburtstag geschenkt würde
ja ok deutschland auch auf unsere
aufgrund unserer geschichte haben wir
nirgendwo flaggen aber uns kommt es auch
komisch ich das ja auch befremdlich als
ich hierhergekommen bin überall flaggen
und dann auf dem tisch liegen welche und
dann hat sich geburtstag wer hat ihnen
freuen uns gebacken und dann verstanden
burgus kleine planken
okay auch wenn man gehörte hatte vor der
tür und hier auch in den hundehaufen
wenn man sie darauf aufmerksam machen
möchte element für alle
stimmt es dass die denon wortkarg sind
ja nur wenige sprache ist auch einfach
nicht so man kann sich nicht so
ausdrücken wie in englischen deutschen
gehört es dem ich nur ein zehntel des
wortschatzes besitzt wie das englische
zum beispiel ist es auch es ist leichter
mit dem schweigen hat mit deutschen
es ist also ich finde etwas angenehmer
weil manchmal eine karte mit italienern
die gut zum beispiel wie können sie
überhaupt nicht gut aber sie müssen ja
immer irgendwelche man bei tränen sind
sogar da läuft man spazieren und kann
aber auch eine halb so nicht sein wenn
ich auch große geschafft ja für das
publikum das ist der eine mag und das
war unsere episode mit julia und franzi
aus
ich danke euch dass in der berlin
noch viel spaß in diesem wunderschönen
land das mir jetzt sehr viel
sympathischer geworden ist durch ihre
erzählung und sowieso und jetzt wollen
wir natürlich von euch wissen was sagt
ihr über dänemark manische meinem
erkennt ihr denen was habt ihr für
erfahrungen mit denen und das soll
natürlich wissen schreibt uns dazu ein
kommentar und wenn ihr noch übungen
bekommen wollt zu dieser episode mit den
vokabeln dabei und den dramatischen
sachen die wir hier benutzt haben
dann werdet unbedingt einen patch in bei
uns ein mitglied und dann bekommt ihr
auch noch übung zu dieser episode
danke fürs zuschauen danke dass ihr
dabei hat und erst jetzt schnell zum tax
treffen
[Musik]
[Applaus]